يعني حقيقه لحظات الانقاذ هذه صراحه لا
يمكن ان ننساها وخاصه لحظات انقاذ الاطفال
اللي انحفرت في عقولنا وقلوبنا ومن بينهم
الطفله اللي انولدت تحت الانقاض في ريف
حلب بمنطقه جنديرس السوريه اقيل انه
المنقذين والدتها متوفيه وهي عايشه والحبل
السري لسه موصول الرضيعه فقدت كل اهلها
وصورها ومقاطعها من المستشفى وصلت كل
انحاء العالم والكل صار بيتابع اخبارها
لحظه بلحظه ويبغى يتطمن على صحتها ووضعها
خاصه وانه ما نجا من عائلتها اي احد
اطلاقا الاهتمام بالرضي عام مل الدنيا
وبدانا نشوف حتى عروض لتبنيها من مشاهير
وحتى الناس من داخل سوريا قالوا انه في
عروض لتبنيها من غير مشاهيره من كل
الجنسيات وطلعت كمان اخبار امس بتقول انه
النجمه انجلينا جولي المعروفه بحبها
للتبني عرضت تتبنى الطفله لكن الفريق
المعالج للر نفس الموضوع وقال انه ما له
اساس من الصحه
الساعات الماضيه سمعنا خبر تاني عنها بس
هذه الخبر كان مفجع فشفنا تقارير عن
محاوله الاختطافها من داخل مستشفى جيهان
اللي بتتلقى فيه الرعايه وقيل انه مجموعه
دخل المستشفى وسالوا عن مكان الرضيعه
وحاولوا يتوجهوا هناك لكن العاملين في
المستشفى منعوهم فاعتدوا عليهم المجهولين
وضربوهم وتركوهم مصابين كمان لكن تمكنوا
من حمايه البنت وما قدروا انه يوصلوا لهم
البنت بالمناسبه من اول لحظه في طبيب في
المستشفى تولى رعايتها وسمعنا انه سماها
ايه وحتى خلى زوجته ترضعها ومتكفل
برعايتها تماما لكن شفنا اخبار تانيه كمان
بتقول انه في اقارب لاسرتها من بعيد ظهروا
وقرروا يسموها عفراء على اسم والده الله
يرحمها